wir haben uns in der euro-krise
jahrelang nur zeit gekauft aber dann mit
der zeit leider nichts gemacht denen die
zinsen minimal hoch rauch der ganze
laden ab spanien hat seit heute auch
regierungskrise europa braucht also
endlich eine langfristige einheitliche
strategie gerade jetzt im konflikt mit
den usa reden wir drüber mit dem
dresdner börsenguru mit olaf schubert
bei damen und herren
[Applaus]
heute schon
oder ist das jetzt das ende der deutsch
amerikanischen freundschaft und wie weit
kann das noch eskalieren
ein krieg muss muss eine freundschaft
nicht unbedingt belassen
also das ist ja so ein bisschen sage ich
mal ja so was wie gewalt in der ehe
also da sind und da sind zwei partner
die sich lieben und klar da gibt es
einen kleinen knopf oder dann fängst du
an kinnhaken ein aber das wichtigste ist
dass sich die die freunde an regeln
halten wenn eben eine unten liegt dass
man dann nur noch einmal nachtritt
aber natürlich sind diese konflikte sage
ich mal zwischenmenschlich und leichter
zu klären als jetzt in der
wirtschaftswelt naja ich meine wenn der
ehepartner nur noch nervt dann kannst du
dir einfach erwürgen
bevor irgendwas eskaliert das geht in
der wirtschaft natürlich nicht man
braucht dann ja dann auch als
handelspartner der muss schon etwas
kaufen kann dir da kannst du also da
kannst du nur maximal so ein bisschen
drosseln und da braucht man halt sehr
viel fingerspitzengefühl und das hat
trump hat absolut ernst erfunden jetzt
heißt es europa muss sich endlich mehr
um sich selber kümmern auch um seinen
militärischen schutz
ist das realistisch ja
machen wir uns nichts vor die zahl der
feinde hat sich verdoppelt
also jetzt im links wie rechts große ich
meine das gute ist wir deutsche kennen
die situation
was natürlich
man muss aber auch sagen es ist mag aber
wie sich geschichte wiederholt dann wenn
es wirklich eng wird dann wird der
italiener von butt also das heißt
natürlich auch die frage sag ich mal ist
dann die bundeswehr überhaupt in der
lage das land zu beschützen wir wissen
ja eine bundeswehr also es ist entweder
alles kaputt oder weg im optimalfall weg
und kaputt wir wissen ja gerade der
deutsche hubschrauber der hat ja
momentan 0 schraubte aber eben verboten
schrauber ist wirklich das letzte
deutsche patent- leider erklärt er wir
sprachen darüber gleichzeitig die
eurokrise zurück nach europa wie
bedrohlich ist das für dich könnte das
das ende des euro sein könnte könnte
wäre wäre fahrradkette ja aber sie ist
wirklich vorstellbar und ich würde das
sehr bedauern denn so eine tolle
gemeinschaftswährung wird den euro haben
wir wirklich nur hier in europa hat man
sich ja was auch gewünscht ist in den
währungsunion in afrika die wollten dort
in afro oder die die juden wünschen sich
ja auch mal so ein eigenes geld in judo
und jetzt setzen hier ist leichtfertig
aufs spiel wegen der italiener ich meine
was steht ihnen herr spaghetti gucci für
harry also meine das bisschen zeug da
stellt ein deutsches mittelständisches
unternehmen das machen die nebenbei so
ja das ist glaube ich die einstellung
die die italiener sollen uns lieben der
der rest von europa reagiert haben sehr
allergisch auf ratschläge aus
deutschland woran liegt das
also ich bin für jeden ratschlag offen
also ich meine ohne ratschläge aus
deutschland sage ich mir dann hätten wir
im osten ja gar nicht überlebt
wir hätten ja nie erfahren was arbeit
ist oder wie schlage ich hab also die
ganz elementaren dinge und natürlich die
anderen länder in europa die sind ein
bisschen wie kinder ein bisschen bockig
sonne und und deutschland ist vaterland
und da muss man natürlich den kindern
irgendwie was erklären so und die kinder
denken ihr hier wirst die eltern
erzählen das ist quatsch aber irgendwann
dann werden die kinder größer das eigene
erfahrung und dann stellen sie fest ja
das war es meine eltern erzählt hat
wieder viele bekloppte als ich dachte
[Applaus]